james cameron's whoa epic all right so
this movie as we all know has been
beyond hype for months maybe even years
but definitely months and we've seen all
the buzz about the special effects but I
know you're thinking yeah yeah we've
heard about the special effects for
months now how is the movie does it have
substance is the acting good is the
script solid first I have to touch on
the special effects since now the table
scraps are all done and I've been in
Pandora for about three hours
the Navi in this movie looks spectacular
as does the world of Pandora at no time
did any of it looked cheesy less than
real or less than amazing for that
matter and as for the characters they
were all great I didn't care about Sam
Worthington before I have't are but now
I think he's cool I hope he sticks
around Michelle Rodriguez didn't
irritate me for once
she's always that chick and everything
she does that feels like she has to
prove something to everyone she's just
not like that in Avatar I actually liked
her for once and Giovanni Ribisi was
straight up Ari Gold light but I liked
him boy I thought his character was a
prick but I liked him
in the role he did a good job Stephen
Lang played the biggest douche since
Biff from Back to the Future and natira
was probably the coolest chick ever put
on film by the end of this movie you
damn near falling over there to whatever
dude just watch the movie you'll see
what I mean but now how was the movie as
a whole the emotion the thick of what we
paid to see does it live up to the
avatar hype lightly put avatar is an
absolute masterpiece very seldomly does
the movie ever surpass ridiculously high
expectations and even more rare is it to
have a great movie that you really have
no complaints about my only complaint is
that this movie is kind of an investment
you have to be emotionally prepared to
watch this movie I heard someone say
that by the time the end conflict in
Avatar happens you are so emotionally
invested in Navi it's like not even
funny
I would have to disagree your emotional
attachment to them runs deep far before
the end of the movie happens I mean you
spend all this time learning the culture
one of the greatest civilizations ever
put on film you live with them you
journey with them you are absolutely
with jakesully you feel happy when he
succeeds you actually want him in natira
to grow close and develop a romance you
like them and the Navi as a whole and I
don't want to ruin anything for you guys
but things happen in this movie that I
was just not prepared to deal with going
in people there are moments in this
movie where if you don't at least almost
cry like if you
not up in the throat you are the most
jaded prick on the face of the planet
you might as well go throw a box of
kittens off a cliff or something because
apparently that's what you're going to
be good at I mean I expected a good
movie or at the very least a really
pretty looking movie but damn it's safe
to say I did not expect this level of
emotional gravity there are scenes that
just break your heart in this movie what
I love is that it's ultimately a love
story between Jake Sully and materi but
it's also this deeper movie about
conflict and sacrifice and what's worth
fighting for what's worth dying for
I mean when's the last time you actually
saw that movie and can say you were
absolutely floored by the gravity of it
the correct answer is tonight if you go
see it like you should I mean so often
we watch a movie where someone has to
fight their fight and we're like yeah
okay fight your fight I'll be watching
you you know works out for you but I
really don't give a [ __ ]
but in Avatar you were straight up like
I will fight for the Navi I will die for
the Navi where do I sign up sign me up
do I sign up here sign me up thank you
you're not gonna pay for my college I
don't give a [ __ ] sign me up
it is so important to you that the na'vi
win and the soundtrack only adds to the
emotional crux being felt the soundtrack
straight up sounds like something out of
civilization for and when the climax of
the movie blasts off then it becomes
civilization for meats epically awesome
in the end we see the kind of movie that
can be made if a director doesn't rush
his moving just takes his time to make
it awesome and what can happen if the
studio backs off and doesn't micromanage
the director at work and as for the 3d
yes the 3d and avatar is amazing but I
do believe that if you end up having to
see the movie in 2d the movie will still
stand up as an awesome movie and impress
you however if you have the choice to
watch it in 2d or 3d you pretty much
have to choose 3d if you don't you are
electing to miss out on a really sweet
aspect of the movie so guys gals people
go see Avatar technologically and
emotionally it absolutely surpasses your
expectations and be prepared to go back
to Pandora a few times over this is
James Cameron's masterpiece by far so go
see it
like right now you're still here go see
it
you